[Musique]
salut c'est monsieur grrrr aujourd'hui
on va parler de la marque française eco
qui a sorti un nouveau produit c'est le
horizon light plus en plus de le tester
pour les invités surprises et on y va
ça c'est l'horizon lie plus qu'on va
tester et ça c'est le horizon lie plus
que je vous offre pour le gagner c'est
super simple vous donne rendez vous sur
ma chaine hi d'itv sur instagram comme
ça vous aurez toutes les infos je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description vous allez voir pas très
compliqué on va donc aujourd'hui parler
de ce horizons les plus je ne sais pas
si vous connaissez la marque eco & co
est une marque française qui fabrique
des smartphones d'entrée de gamme des
produits qui ont la particularité les
dessiner au studio 107 sont plutôt
franchement bien réussi donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va ouvrir ses horizons
les plus ensemble on va regarder comment
il est fait on a regardé un petit plus
qu'est dans le ventre on va le voir un
peu tous les côtés et on va regarder à
qui il est destiné
voilà donc la boîte voilà quoi ça
s'entend change un peu des packagings
traditionnels voici la marque du
fabricant éco-compatible tout opérateur
dans sa jolie boîte en plastique on va
l'ouvrir
et hop ouvert alors comment ça marche
est-ce qu'il faut avoir fait sciences po
pour réussir à ouvrir ce truc smartphone
horizon like plus grand écran ici nous
avons une batterie c'est à dire hyper
rare aujourd'hui d'avoir des batteries
qu'on peut changer comme ça ça peut être
un point positif
nous avons également un câble usb vers
usb type c'est ici le chargeur est ici
une paire d'écouteurs toutes les infos
sur les garanties d infos là sur le
smartphone pour comprendre comment il
fonctionne
pour vous le précise dessus nouveau
format grand écran ce soir vous avez un
écran de 5 points 7 pouces c'est une
dalle ipc du lcd ratio 18/9 définition
c'est du hd + voilà la bête
c'est vrai que c'est un format qui se
fait énormément et qui est plutôt pas
mal
alors comment ça marche pour venir
mettre cette petite batterie ça c'est
l'équipe cela ici vous avez la place
pour insérer une micro carte sim pour
l'asim c'est une micro sim pour la
deuxième c'est une anonyme dont vous
mettez votre micro sim ici vous mettez
ici votre l'anoci et si vous avez
emplacement pour une carte micro sd
je prends donc ma petite batterie que je
vais venir clip c'est là je remets mon
petit dos il ya une protection d'écran
pour bien protéger c'est pas mal pour ya
des petites bulles pour l'installation
pas toujours évident à poser mais en
tout cas c'est plutôt bien que ce soit
pensée et que ce soit directement
intégrée du point de vue de l' os c'est
un androïde 7.0 nougat vous avez votre
tiroir d'appui qui est là bon après
c'est un grand classique côté puissance
à l'intérieur c'est un media take out et
6737 qu'annoncé jusqu'à 3 giga hertz
quatre coeurs de giga de ram 32 go de
stockage que vous pouvez monter jusqu'à
64 go de stockage en tout avec une carte
de 32 gigas maximum la batterie
intérieur c'est une 3 millions en faire
un appareil photo arrière de 13
mégapixels un à l'avant au de 5
mégapixels pouvait faire des vidéos en
full hd 1920 par 1080 que vous avez bien
évidemment votre lecteur d'empreintes
digitales ici pour venir déverrouiller
directement votre appareil il se
recharge en usb type c il a une prise
jack d'un poids du design il ya plutôt
pas mal ce que j'aime bien moi c'est
cette finition métal brossé que vous
avez à l'arrière qui donne un côté assez
classieux assez premium et vous voyez ci
destinée aux 116 assemblé en chine sa
comme tous les téléphones aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu' un design qui est superbe
vous avez le logo est qu ici pour
trouver les mêmes couleurs à l'avant
comme à l'arrière vous avez des bords
arrondis même l'écran ici et arrondies
des petites border son côté une bordure
sur l'eau une bordure en bas c'est aussi
un grand classique vous retrouvez
également le logo est qu en bacs et pas
mal d'un point de vue design je trouve
franchement réussie il est dans les
standards actuels avec un bouton pour
l'allumer bouton de volume ici pour
parleur mono de ce point de vue là je
trouve bien du point de vue de l'écran
vous pouvez bien évidemment ce que vous
regardez vos vidéos les iron
tracy a point de vue sont s'est pas
complètement dingue là je suis à fond on
n'a pas un son qui crachent dans notre
côté on va pas lui demander la lune
c'est un smartphone qui coûte 139 euros
trop indices mais c'est vrai qu'il
manque un petit peu de puissance en
terme de performance assez pâle arrive à
être le plus réactif
néanmoins pour l'utilisation standard ça
fait la sphère point de vue photo vous
avez de la prise en charge du hdr petite
particularité lorsque vous voulez
utiliser la caméra de celle fille si
vous avez lu hdr qu'activer vous avez
cherché pendant longtemps il faut
désactiver le hdr pour retrouver ici up
est passé en caméra telle fille vous
avez un mode de prise de vue normale
vous avez du panorama en option via une
mode beauté visage vous pouvez calais un
anti tremblement si vous le souhaitez et
détection automatique de scène et pour
la vidéo vous avez la possibilité de
choisir la qualité soit élevé haute
qualité faible ou moyenne selon vos
souhaits lorsque vous utilisez pour
filmer en plein jour le résultat
fonctionne vous serez pas déçus
après vous en ai parlé truc de dingue
c'est pas une caméra extraordinaire 13
mégapixels mais c'est pas non plus un
capteur de fou c'est pas non plus un
objectif de dingue pour se faire des
souvenirs partagés sur les réseaux
sociaux
ça marchera par contre été vous avez pu
trop luminosité tout de suite c'est moi
ça je suis faible luminosité
ça fait là faire pour faire des
visioconférences loin de ses amis pour
faire du skype ça fonctionnera pour
quelques souvenirs
sacha la chair aussi mais pas trop lui
en demander parce que c'est pas sa
spécialité
vous vous en douterez sur le décor il en
ait plus on n'est pas sur un smartphone
premium on est sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme
néanmoins pour un primo accédants ça
peut faire un excellent smartphone point
vraiment très positif de ce produit
c'est le design je trouve très jolie
point un peu négatif forcément mais
parce que dans cette catégorie de
produits les photos les vidéos vont pas
être génial la puissance est
complètement dingue c'est une fois de
plus normal sera smartphone à moins de
140 euros
il chauffe un petit peu ça pourrait
aussi être un peu son point négatif vous
avez la batterie est quand même juste
ici donc ça paraît pas complètement
anormal je trouve plutôt pas mal pour
les primo accédants ou pour tous ceux
qui veulent un smartphone pas cher sous
android à moins de 140 euros
ce horizon light plus peut faire affaire
dite mangou ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est-ce que vous avez déjà vu
des produits de chez qu est-ce que cette
marche vous plaît marque française
il faut préciser ya beaucoup de marques
françaises sur le marché
même si effectivement aujourd'hui est
une marque française peau est une marque
d'ouvriers dans le monde
vous allez forcément faire fabriquer en
chine c'est là-bas que passe le business
donc dites moi ce que vous en pensez de
mots ce que vous pensez de ico ce que
vous pensez de ce smartphone et moi s'il
pourrait vous tenter et selon vous à qui
se destine ce produit n'oubliez pas de
tenter votre chance pour gagner je vous
invite tous les liens en bas dans la
description d'ici là soyez sa santé vous
bien je vous dis à très bientôt atteint
[Musique]